an island cut in two look to the north
and you can see the Turkish cypriot side
of a frozen conflict from 48 years ago
a self-declared state only recognized by
the Turkish government in Ankara its
leaders say they want more influence in
the Mandate of the United Nations run
buffer zone that segregates them from
the majority Greek cypriots south of the
island hello two this is Tutu Charlie
video takeover and there are tensions on
both sides the fact that the thighs do
not talk to each other creates an
opportunity for insecurity and that's
where the role of the United Nations is
critical we have open communication
lines with both sides and we work
closely with both sides on a daily basis
the buffer zone has an eerie Stillness
it's a place that belies the clamor of
derision between people on both sides of
it time here hasn't moved on from 1974.
it's a no-go Zone giving bygone
snapshots of a conflict that took homes
away from owners and left lives and
property in Ruins
even what was nicosia's International
Airport is caught in the time warp the
structure remains but little else the
un's role is to ensure it stays as it is
the last time a plane flew out of here
was in 1974 like the differences between
Greek cypriots and Turkish cypriots it's
Frozen in Time both politically and
physically
and now there are new tensions Turkish
separately does a demanding equal rights
with the Cyprus government in
negotiating with the UN or they may take
undisclosed action you always get more
cyber rattling when there are no
negotiations going on to solve the
Cyprus problem and we've now gone a good
five years plus without any negotiations
the U.N presence runs through urban
districts and swathes of Countryside
180 kilometers across the island
it's one of the longest running U.N
peacekeeping operations in the world
now into its sixth decade with no sign
of an end
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera Nicosia